[Music]
you of all people should know there's
plenty wrong with me
love what you've done with the place
you
hilgers loose
it I should thank you captioning goose
way I so much easier than
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new Arkham
trailer if you guys did know what's
going on I'm just going to do a
breakdown it's basically the first
couple of games but it's only on like
ps4 and xbox one this isn't going to be
on PC what's going on here is this is
basically arkham city in the original
arkham game remastered for ps4 and xbox
one so you can see from the trailer what
some of the textures look like but
you're basically it's like the game of
the year edition remastered so you're
basically getting like all the dlc
pretty much everything they released for
those games they've been polished for
the ps4 just because it's been so long
since they came out and just to be clear
this is not Arkham origins that's a
different game like I had to browse
through my Steam library to make sure
that I didn't already own all this stuff
and once I read through the white paper
on it I'm like okay this is a different
game sometimes it's hard to tell like
they're remastering an old game but have
they already released like a bundled
version of it with some other games no
this is a brand new think they just
released it now like this hasn't been
released before this year so you're
effectively getting arkham asylum game
of the year edition in Arkham City game
of the year edition to like you know two
of the best batman games ever the Arkham
games are amazing and everyone was
really bummed after Arkham Knight when
they're like we're not going to be
making any more Arkham games but they
just announced red dead redemption too
so that's basically like the next huge
game they're working on for next year
I'll do the video for that later this
week because of a huge fan of the
western genre and that was one of the
best games i played on my 360 a long
time ago it seems like it's been so long
since that came out but let me know what
you guys thought about the original
Arkham games and I like we talked a lot
about Arkham Knight when it came out I
even did a couple of gameplay videos for
it on my gameplay channel which is just
called Charlie's dreams so hopefully
I'll find some time to do some more
gameplay videos because that's usually
like my default go to when I'm not
watching movies or TV like if there's
nothing on that I'm gonna be doing a
video for I have one of those classic
problems were you just blind by a lot of
cheap steam games just because they look
amazing but then never find the time to
play them so for those asking like all
my Arkham games I've bought for ps4 just
because I felt like the experience was a
little bit better on ps4 and say a
prayer for everyone that was
unfortunate enough to buy arkham knight
on pc that is one of the reasons why
you're not seeing pc versions of this
the remastered versions they kind of
took that version of the game just
rolled it up into a ball and threw it
into the trash can just because there
was so many problems with the pc port
but get hype is gonna be awesome and
there's a whole bunch of other stuff
happening today so i'm gonna try and get
a luke cage video out before the flash
starts Jesse quick on the flash tonight
so be sure to subscribe to get all that
stuff and for those of you that didn't
like play all the way through the Arkham
series usually when they start doing the
DLC like after the main game comes out
and a little time has gone by they start
releasing dlc they'll put easter eggs in
four games that are coming up so like
the Batman VR game that's only on ps4
don't get me started on that I'm
actually really pissed about that but
they actually like when they were doing
dlc for Arkham Knight recently they laid
in Easter eggs for the Batman VR game
like the story of it spelled out on the
wall maps whenever you play the keys on
the piano and Wayne Manor so if you're
willing to spend like the extra billion
hours to play through the gate like the
extra little bits of the game you can
get early information on games that are
coming up before they publicly announced
them so Luke Age Iron Fist Heroes for
Hire coming in a little while well you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my superman and supergirl
beating the [ __ ] out of metallo video
from last night and you can click here
for the flash jesse quick trailer for
tonight's episode thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight